years have passed since large-scale
organized child abuse was exposed in
rotherham but two whistleblowers say
senior police officers are still
avoiding scrutiny for their failings a
strategic drugs analyst at south
yorkshire police angie heal first
reported drugs gangs were also sexually
exploiting children 20 years ago so the
first report i did was in 2002 and that
was looking at crack cocaine nuisance
supply in south yorkshire and that's
when i came across the issue of child
sexual exploitation because i hadn't
heard of it before so i was really
shocked
[Music]
angie wrote three reports over four
years but felt no one was listening
decade later after an independent
inquiry found hundreds of young girls
were being sexually abused by gangs
angie complained about the failure of
senior officers to act teaming up with
youth worker jane senior who contacted
the independent office for police
conduct the iopc
i got a very angry telephone call saying
um
very clearly um that if i continue down
this path i need to be very aware
that there's actually legislation and if
vexatious complainants
continue to complain
there is legislation that could be
looking up to two years imprisonment who
was saying that you could go to prison
the aopc
jane had been awarded an mbe for
exposing the grooming gang scandal she'd
been invited to downing street and was
given a commander's award after the
successful prosecution of a gang but now
trying to expose senior police failings
she was in a battle with the police
watchdog i remember going home and
saying to my husband something along the
lines wow it's like the mafia
you know you try to go for them at the
top
and everybody around them just just
comes out fighting
last week angie and jane were vindicated
the police watchdog upheld their
complaint but the full report into
senior officers seen by sky news was not
published aspects of it were included in
a broader review called operation linden
but with no mention of high-ranking
officers it's not highlighted at all you
have to know what you're looking for it
doesn't mention its
senior officers it's not really
commented on until page 112.
it's virtually the last section of the
report
report into senior officers does
strongly criticize the failed strategy
at the top but it doesn't name officers
and makes clear there was a lack of
cooperation the iopc has limited powers
when it comes to interviewing witnesses
and they say they contacted several
retired police officers who worked in
intelligence and child protection but in
their report they say they would not
engage with us and we couldn't force
them to do so and this has been a
barrier to obtaining evidence
south yorkshire police say they accept
the recommendations of the regulator but
not criticisms where no individual is
identified the police watchdog told sky
news we're proud of the impact this work
had and the real changes in policing we
expect to see as a result our priority
has always been the welfare of the
survivors we recognize that some of the
outcomes will not be what was hoped for
but every single case we looked into has
helped inform our recommendations that
aim to ensure others do not have to go
through the same experiences
but these two women say the process for
complaining against senior officers
remains murky and is not fit for purpose
jason farrell sky news